my name is Ryan and I've never eaten
fruit it's just something that I've
never wanted to do before this
my parents have definitely tried to get
me to eat fruit but I've absolutely
rejected that yeah I want to eat fruit
because I really feel like I'll feel
better about myself I'll look better so
I'm here today cuz I really want to give
it a go and I think it's gonna help me
in the long run do you believe in me as
my father I'm extremely scared the
texture kind of scares me I mean what's
going on here with this pineapple I just
don't like fruit it's that simple but
today I'm gonna risk it all and try some
food a blueberry is that correct I don't
like it already it's leaking it's got a
little hole right here it's the first
time I'm ever trying or it just leaked
out
it's listed first forever here I go
[Music]
hmm that wasn't bad
I almost gagged it at first did you see
that I really don't have anything much
to say about the blueberry I'm not blown
away by it
but a five but I am proud of myself for
trying that because it was small but it
was scary at first that's my first fruit
yeah all right I just tried it great
I know it's a [ __ ] grape thank you
maybe I should cut this in half thank
you
there's that gag reflex again my eyes
are watering that was like you bite into
it and it's just like an explosion of
glorification I would stop tomato for
the blueberry was better next fruit it
smells sweet this is a big piece but I'm
gonna go for it I kind of like that
I think that's number one so far that
goes above the blueberry I'm gonna give
this shrub area seven Oh God what the
[ __ ] is that okay what the [ __ ] is this
this looks like a sea creature it smells
kind of good Oh
oh my god I hate that the texture of
this is so weird that it feels like it's
alive it's not on the scale it's it's
the zero is this a mango I like that it
doesn't have seeds or eggs or anything
crazy in it that's not how I expected it
to taste it tastes a little like salary
I was telling my friends I was like I
really think I'm gonna connect with
mango on a different level and that's
not what happened today we were rooting
for you mango
well it doesn't smell like apple juice
right out to me that tastes like apple
juice you know makes sense that was that
was pretty good I like that I definitely
like the crunchy er ones and now I can
envision my future with apples like
people dip them and peanut butter
what else do you have back there this is
the one that I know is gonna give me
problems I do not like banana look at
this thing
this is gonna give me a problem I I
don't like the smell of them I don't
like the peeling I don't like how
obnoxious it looks because I've done so
much and I have conquered all those
fruit I'm actually gonna eat this whole
thing I hate a too soft too like gooey
too slimy I like orange juice this is
why I'm so like messed up hopefully it
tastes like a screwdriver top debauch
mmm that was good I really like that
yeah can I try another piece of it this
is where I'm at right now
I have just tried an orange a legit
orange and now I'm asking for another
orange out of ten I'm gonna give it a 10
[Music]
there's a see Venus I don't really like
that it's it's a little spongy a
watermelon is deftly a hard three my
friend Carly is like obsessed with
pineapples she always says that I'm
gonna love them the pineapple is so
extra like can we just take a second to
talk about this it smells really good
though hmm
Oh Bob another I don't say so myself I
feel like this is another ten this and
orange are my are gonna be like my go-to
I think I did it
I just tried ten fruit my whole life
I've seen for him like I'm not going
near that I don't want to try that and I
just tried ten so I'm really proud of
myself this could open up new
possibilities of trying new foods with
different textures so I just tried ten
fruit they almost had to at some point
[Applause]
[Music]